back in college our favorite bar decided  that it wasn't going to have a dj and a  dance floor anymore and this was  devastating for the binge drinking  community because it was the only bar in  town that had a dj and a dance floor so  we decided to do something about  it i remember about one of the most  united communities we have on campus  binge drinkers now  the community of elmer's college binge  drinkers are looking for a place to go  on saturday nights and i'd like to talk  to some of the managers in the area to  discuss the possibility of when and  where dj we can find a dj and a dance  floor to break it down  if you could call me back at 8 45